the first day of the G20 Summit in New
Delhi head of the host nation around
remodi announced the group had finally
reached a consensus on a Leader's
declaration
hard one after days of negotiation to
overcome deep divisions about the war in
Ukraine it calls against the use of
force to seize territory something some
members believe Moscow has already done
and describing the use of nuclear
weapons as inadmissible
it noted Divergent views on the conflict
but included a more unified call to do
more to tackle climate crisis and
provide much needed debt relief to
emerging economies
many of them have still not recovered
particularly in Africa and even many
parts of Asia many have not recovered
from the blow that the pandemic
inflicted on their economy the group
agreed to an annual fund of 4 trillion
dollars to accelerate the transition to
renewable energy and six trillion
dollars before 2030 to help developing
countries reach emissions targets
earlier African Union chairperson azali
asumani was warmly welcomed as he took
his seat at the G20 table for the first
time the addition was welcomed by the
au's 55 member States including South
Africa which was previously the only
African member of the G20 for us it was
not a sustainable that you could have
more than a billion people excluded the
move was put forward by Modi who was
eager to Project New Delhi as a leader
for developing countries law analysts
say it still lags behind Beijing when it
comes to influence on the world stage as
a provider of infrastructure as a
provider of Aid as a provider of
military assistance India simply can't
match China's offering however the first
day ended with an initiative designed to
do just that the announcement by the U.S
and its allies to build an economic
Corridor linking India to the Middle
East and Europe
this is a big deal
this is a real big deal the economic
Corridor is seen as a plan to rival
China's Belton Road initiative which
connects Asia to Africa and Europe
Chinese president Xi Jinping was absent
from this year's Summit for the first
time since coming to power leading some
to believe that he's choosing to focus
instead on groupings like the bricks
where beijing's voice is more dominant
katrinau Al Jazeera New Delhi
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera